приєднує до нашої студії міністра освіти
та науки України Сергія шкарлета пане
Сергію Вітаю вас вітаю вас Слава Україні
Героям слава зараз увага всієї країни
безумовно прикута до Херсонщини до
відновлення нормального життя у
звільнених районах Чи є у вас інформація
про масштаби руйнування саме освітньої
інфраструктури на звільненій частині
Херсонської області Дуже дякую за
запитання важке запитання оскільки
знаєте Ну саме про руйнування про те як
знищувалося освіта важко говорити мені
як освітянино адже ну на сьогодні надо
окуповані території на п'ятницю у нас
було 15 16 територіальних громад на якій
знаходились 137 шкіл в тому числі 59 у
місті Херсон - це дошкільної освіти було
130 дитячих садочків 75 у Херсоні
поправтех у світі 12 закладів від 9 з
них у Херсоні в нас зруйновано 22
заклади це 14 шкіл п'ять садочків п'ять
просять не технічних навчальних закладів
інші навіть Пошкодження від 50 до 90%.
це взагалі Ну така якась варварська
варварське відношення з відношення саме
до освіти до цивільної інфраструктури в
нас найбільше пошкоджень саме в
сільській місцевості
матеріальна база закладів розграбована і
нам там
є чим займатися після деокупації
більшість частина деокупованих територій
знаходиться в відстані вогневого
ураження тому вільний доступ до будівель
для проведення оцінки технічного стану
на сьогодні дуже досить обмежений і ми
здійснюємо всі можливі оперативні заходи
разом з нацполіцією разом з
Владою українською Яка повернулася до
деокупованих громад для того щоб
зберегти будівлі після руйнування цей
закриття вікон да- дахів плівкою
проводимо очистка приміщень від
будівельних уламків а всього 84 заклади
пошкоджено з них 48 школ 23 садочки
шість про тих п'ять профтехів два
заклади виборчої освіти ну маємо над
складні руйнування які які на сьогодні
об'єктивно показують чим вартує руський
мір і хто його там чекав
Яке ваше бачення відновлення навчального
процесу на Херсонщині коли доступу до
шкіл фізично немає частина шкіл
зруйнована замінована і ще й немає
електроенергії
ви знаєте в цілому Херсонській області у
нас розпочало роботу 157 шкіл звісно всі
в дистанційній формі з них 87 закладів
вже на деокуповані території і в нас
охоплено дистанційним навчанням 65 тисяч
дітей з них три майже 37 тисяч дітей з
звільнених територій і 27 школярів з
міста Херсона 4000 учителів працюють
організовують освітні програми саме за
українськими стандартами і на сьогодні
керівники цих закладів організовували
роботу з підконтрольних територій
України проводилась роботи долучення
дітей з окупованих територій і на
сьогодні ще окуповані громади діти
долучені максимально долучені до
освітнього процесу за українськими
стандартами звісно в дистанційній формі
ми вирішуємо питання щодо відновлення
освітнього процесу в закладах вищої
освіти які повернулися до території
України а також залучення дітей з
окупованих територій в нас в принципі на
наступній на наступний тиждень буде
завезена
2300 ноутбуків від Hewlett Packard за
сприянням першої леді України Олени
зеленської до Херсонської області і це
дасть певний поштовх для організації
дистанційного навчання на сьогодні
проводиться розмінування території
підключення до Інтернету і після
проведення цих закладів ми заходів ми
чітко розраховуємо на на якомога більшу
можливість покриття
зв'язком території Херсонщини в тому
числі окупований де окупований для
залучення максимальної кількості дітей
до освітнього процесу до деокупації чи
відбувався там
псевдонавчальний процес під керівництвом
окупаційної влади на Херсонщині Чи
ходили діти до тих
Я не знаю як це назвати до тих місць які
називались в Україні школами
ви знаєте окупаційна влада дійсно
оголосила початок освітнього процесу за
російськими стандартами але не сталося
так як гадалося оскільки лише один
відсоток викладачів погодився на
співпрацю і більшість закладів в повному
сезоні не розпочали роботу анонси так і
залишились анонсами діти до шкіл не
пішли переважній більшості початок
нового навчального року в деяких
закладах переносився декілька разів
з деяких предметів взагалі не було
вчителів їх відвозили з інших регіонів в
Росії освітяни Херсонщини більш
переважній більшості свої відмовились
від співпраці з окупантами керівників
закладів окупованих закладів освіти
взагалі призначали будь-кого осіб які не
те що не мали педагогічної освіти
взагалі були без освіти були випадки
коли директор школи приходив до школи
всі дав на стульчику біля біля закладу
освіти а діти до школи так вони йшли а
наші діти з окупованих територій попри
перепони доєднувались до онлайн навчання
в своїх рідних школах Херсонщини
навчалися за українськими програмами
нашої освітяни наші діти це справжні
герої ми пишаються вся країна і не
тільки вся країна набу весь світ
підтвердив високий рівень навчання
освітнього процесу освітніх стандартів
саме України Дякую вам за такі запитання
а от якщо лише один відсоток українських
вчителів погодилися на співпрацю з
окупантами на Херсонщині і в інших
регіонах там такий самий в інших
тимчасово окупованих показник чи є десь
більше відсоток співпраці Ні в нас в
цілому по країні Один відсоток погодився
і це це робить честь нашим освітянам
Дуже дякую
То хто тоді в цих псевдошколах викладає
це от всі російські вчителі туди
поприїжджали чи де вони набирають
персонал для того щоб якось створювати
видимість навчального процесу яка
специфіка цього навчального процесу
Дякую вам за запитання ще раз повторюю
що в більшості закладів освіти взагалі
освітній процес не розпочався взагалі
дата дата перенос дата початку навчання
переносили з декілька разів більшість
предметів взагалі не охоплені вчителями
ті які змогли вони охопити вони завозили
з інших регіонів Росії за там над великі
добові за надвелику зарплату але при
цьому діти як продовжували навчатись в
українських школах онлайн за
українськими стандартами так воно і було
як вчителі продовжували викладати і
зберігати освітній процес за
українськими стандартами для і в тому
числі для окупованих дітей так воно і
відбувалося яка Міністерства щодо того
одного відсотку вчителів які погодилися
працювати за російськими програмами чи
вони всі уже названі записані
кількість вчителів ще раз повторюю
тільки вчителів вкрай низька які
погодились працювати з і погодились на
колабораційні дії співпрацювати з
окупантами і в тому числі наскільки Ми
співпрацюємо з правоохоронним органами
прізвища майже всіх відомі вони
абсолютно будуть відповідати в повній
мірі перед законом за свої колабораційні
дії і але це справа
правоохоронних органів Я сподіваюсь що
всі будуть притягнуті трудові відносини
з такими особами припинені
органи місцевого самоврядування
військово-адміністрації які повернулися
до деокупованих територій постійно дбали
і дбають про вчителів в нас на сьогодні
по Херсонській області залишилось ще
тільки чотири громади які не охоплені
заробітною платою Міністерство всіх всі
всі перерахування здійснило але є певні
наприклад не було електронного зв'язку
не було електронних ключів не було тоді
керівника закладу освіти Сьогодні ми
повністю в найближчі часи в порядку
впорядкуємо це І будемо будемо точно
наших освітян будемо будемо і надалі
співпрацювати і підтримувати наших
заробітні плати вчителі Херсонщини
звільненої миколаївщини уже найближчим
часом Так отримують в повному обсязі те
що вони не змогли отримувати Під час
окупації
там лише декілька громад наприклад по
Херсонській області у нас лише 4 громади
Які би не було охоплені приблизно 5
тисяч вчителів ми чітко знаємо що це там
в одній громаді це серпень вересень і
жовтень в двох громадах вереса ніжовтень
і в 1/4 громаді лише жовтень а
найближчим часом це буде впорядковано
будуть оформлені реєстри будуть надані
допуски електронних ключів керівникам і
ця ситуація впорядкується навіть ті хто
виїхав
виїхав з території Херсонщини і не мали
змогу працювати Вони були на простої дві
третини зарплати їм кожному з них
нараховано Я сподіваюсь що тим часом всі
наші освітяни отримують ту частину яку
яку На жаль їм поки заборгували зараз
коли вже навчальний проце Херсонщині
буде
відновлюватися в повному обсязі так як
це би мало бути у нас в Україні то чи
вистачає там вчителів навіть для
дистанційного навчання
ви знаєте у нас десь на 98% комплектація
викладачів є в тому числі і на
деокупованих територіях там де такого
немає ми на сьогодні
співпрацюємо з педагогічними закладами
вищої освіти з аспірантами з магістрами
для того щоб хоча б тимчасово підхопити
ті предмети які не забезпечені вчителями
для того щоб аспіранти змогли дітей Не
залишити від від доступу до освітнього
процесу
Ну і сьогодні знову Укренерго попереджає
про те що точніше інформує про те що
будуть планові відключення світла у
кількох регіонах Звісно ж це сильно
впливає на навчальний процес коли
вчитель в одному регіоні у нього в один
час включається світло учня може він
буде в іншому регіоні там в інший час
виключається світло як налагоджується
оцей процес Роботи під час вієлових
відключень які як знову ж таки
попереджає Укренерго уже можуть сягати з
часом і 10 і 12 годин якщо виникне Ну от
потреба в таких відключеннях
ви знаєте відключення світла це
необхідна міра для збереження
енергетичної стабільності по всій країні
На жаль ми знаходимось в період
повномасштабної російської агресії під
час війни і вимушені все ж таки
пристосовуватись під певні особливості в
тому числі і ведення освітнього процесу
з головолом обласних військових
адміністрацій на постійному контакті я
постійно перебуваю в
більшості з регіонів України де можливо
як правило під час уроків ми намагаємось
не відключати саме школи і заклади
освіти від світла однак окремий випадки
звісно є Ми плануємо це певну змінність
в навчанні Ми плануємо певні
години занять які поверталися до частини
перевірки залишкових знань під час
самостійної роботи ми Закликаємо всіх
батьків в тому числі долучитись до
цієї ситуації вимушеної ситуації
відключення енергії в тому числі
намагатися займатися з дітьми також
додатково ще і
це вимушена міра і я сподіваюсь що так
як і все інше ми все одно це переборемо
переможемо і будемо рухатись лише на
випередження в будь-якому випадку
бажання навчатися це основне що формує
Результат навчання але при цьому Ми
зробили декілька в тому числі і
офлайн-ресурсів ми сьогодні всі наші
ресурси всеукраїнську школу онлайн і
наші додатки застосунки до
[музика]
телефонів і гаджетів Ми сьогодні
намагаємось робити їх геміфікованими і
незалежними від інтернету для того щоб
дитина закачавши один раз їх на планшет
могла повернутись до вивчення певної
теми перевірити свої залишкові знання
записати свої запитання до вчителя коли
він може бути на постійному контакті з
вчителем ми на сьогодні зробили більше
ніж
1335 назв підручників з першого по 11-й
клас які викладені на сайті інституту
модерні змісту освіти Який теж можна
закачати собі в девайс і таким чином
планувати свій освітній процес незалежно
від світла поки поки є заряд повного
одного з девайсів робимо по рівень знань
українських учнів не знижувався навіть
під час війни